[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity the free speech week at Berkeley
is scheduled to kick off on Sunday but
their reports tonight that it is
canceled
but the organizer as of today says the
event is still on although he is holding
a press conference tomorrow
last night Hannity spoke with recording
artist Kaia Jones and joy Villa who were
going to attend the event but decided
not to after they received death threats
take a look this is serious
free speech Berkeley the whole speech
movement yeah that happened don't worry
speech week right we were asked to come
out and we had threats on our life yeah
like we've had serious threats and I
couldn't get any security in time we
have security and so there is no we
don't live there so it's kind of just
tricky and they were asking us to come
in early to do something for them it
just it's yeah you've seen what's
happened when conservatives trying to
noir that it's horrible I mean we're
doing we're doing our best to try and
bring the nation together we're singing
songs that are pro-america her song you
know make America great again what is
wrong with that I'm thinking about what
the hearts don't know and paying homage
to military film your videos are amazing
both your songs are amazing I post them
by the end of the show on my car awesome
both incredible so it's got to be scary
it's horrible
it's intimidation to the highest degree
I mean we just came from Euston raising
three million dollars for the relief
100% of the proceeds go to the relief
and we're trying to just be out with
Milo speaking be a part of you know free
speech week yeah and being told you're
gonna have yourself in a riot and you
want to kill you and you know how could
you do that and who are you guys to
think that you're you know able to have
that kind of pull and it's like we're
actually supposed to be singing and
we're not you know you know strangers to
death threats we do get a lot of them
because we're out for Trump that's but
this time they made specific threats on
our life they said we're going to come
there we're going to find you we're
going to kill you and like I said we
don't have the pool right now to get our
security together we have small security
team on the grounds there but our
management
this is really dangerous okay so my it's
gotta be disheartening for you yeah all
right so you're both artists yes we
understand most singers most performers
most entertainers are liberal right okay
but you're conservative by the way which
makes me like you more so the question
is and Americans like the fact that wow
there's some people that have their own
political thoughts right how hard has it
been as supporters of Trump it's been
honestly almost impossible we have to
force our way into some things we have
to speak up even stronger because a lot
of people turn their backs like on the
red carpet they'll turn their backs on
us they won't take photos of us or they
won't promote us for me I've been told
you're not welcome here I'm Oh Scott
común example oh joy
Fashion Week it was in March in Los
Angeles right after the Grammys where I
wore my make America great again dress
one of the organizers of Fashion Week
heard I was coming and I was coming as a
VIP to watch the designer who happened
to be one of my good friends and he said
no not that Trump girl she's not allowed
here I mean I came anyways through the
designer but if he had control over the
situation he would have black blacklist
Ally from Fashion Week indifferent
censorship as well I mean YouTube was
censoring me with my views they're
taking away views and they were
censoring joy and it was due to the fact
that you know I mean what other reason
could is it been an upside in other
words there's another group of people
that appreciate the fact that there are
entertainers that like the president and
I mean I think if you're gonna if you're
gonna pose your narrative and you're
gonna be strong and in your way and
finding your lane you're going to not
have everyone love you the president
knows that right not everybody loves him
oh I kind of know it a little you know a
little too but that's the point is if
you're gonna change the world or you're
gonna be a figure you have to know that
not everyone's gonna agree with you or
see you know eye-to-eye but over time
hopefully they'll understand that it's
all for the better and we have young
fans honestly I have to stay on YouTube
for my 13 year old fans who are
conservatives who write me every day who
say I look up to you joy because I'm
I get made fun of in school or my
parents will understand and there's so
many Young Conservatives right now
there's a huge movement so having two
singers that they can look up to it
makes it all worth it